okay so in light of Donald Trump's
recent Twitter pronouncement about
banning all transgender military service
members from serving in the military in
any capacity I thought that it would be
a good time to go back to my interview
from October of 2014 with Brett Jones
who is the first openly gay maybe seal I
don't think that the connection requires
any more explanation Brett did go into
how he was actually interrogated about
his sexuality when he was in the
military Don't Ask Don't Tell plays a
role in our interview and just think
about what Brett Jones told me back in
2014 in light of Donald Trump's clearly
expressed desire to ban all transgender
military service members from serving in
the United States military let's get
into that interview now I'm joined today
by Brett Jones who's a former Navy SEAL
currently living in Alabama where he and
his husband run a business together
Brett I've been really researching and
reading about your story over the last
couple days getting ready for our
interview and there's so many
interesting elements to it let's maybe
start it when you first had the idea
that you might want to get into the
military okay so tell us about that well
I remember I was living in Egypt at the
time and I overheard a conversation
between my father and my brother and my
father at the time was a colonel in the
Air Force and he was an ambassador's
aide there at the Embassy in Cairo and
he came back and told the story about
how he wasn't even allowed to see these
guys called Navy SEALs and you know at
the time he really didn't know a whole
lot about them he had heard of them in
Vietnam and some reasons and I had a
planet exceeding me that it was just
neat that you know even my dad wasn't
allowed to see him or know who they were
and what year did you finally join up a
join the Navy in 1993 and then what was
the path from joining the Navy until you
were ultimately part of the Navy SEALs
well it was a it was a path kind of
reels with a lot of obstacles I went
through
I joined the nating went through boot
camp and then my a school and then from
there went to Budds which is the
precursor for seal training and I didn't
make it through my first time I went to
Iceland as a Navy policeman did that for
a while and worked really hard to be
able to get the opportunity to try to
become a seal again and second time I
went through I made it and I was pretty
much the path to to give me you know
obviously I get to you you get to your
SEAL team and you still have about six
months worth of training and advanced
training to do before you become a seal
but that initial six months of buzz
training is the toughest so in the
background of all this of course there's
your sexuality and you you of course had
to have been aware of what the policy
was in the military back in 1993 what
impact or how did that kind of interface
with your desires to be in the military
is that something you thought about yeah
I definitely thought about it you know
when I joined they had the the Don't Ask
Don't Tell policy was sort of new yeah
and I you know I knew instinctively at
the time that it was kind of a load of
crap so I just knew going in that I was
going to have to I'm going to have to do
a lot of line and is that what it was
was that you know some people talk about
their experience in the military under
Don't Ask Don't Tell as being more I
guess Don't Ask Don't Tell in the sense
that they didn't directly feel that they
had to lie they kind of fell out of
place when there may have been
conversations where they may not
necessarily have felt included based on
their sexuality but the direct line
wasn't really a part of it but for you
it was oh yeah yeah it definitely was
see the thing is is the SEAL team
community is a very tight-knit community
and there's not very many of us and so
you spend a lot of time and and at that
very small environment it gets very
difficult to keep you know a lie like
that or our secret like that from from
the guys you work with and what kinds of
situations would there be where you just
had to just lie
well I remember they kept a lot of the
guys kept asking me you know about you
know any girlfriends or anything like
that and I remember it got so bad that
at one point a friend of mine actually
posed as my girlfriend to a couple of
you know get-togethers that we had in
the Philippines so this wasn't in
pictures this was she actually would
show up places with you yeah yeah it was
it was like a comedy it was well
probably a comedy of errors more than
anything yeah well I mean I can
understand why there's this kind of
funny element of it looking back but at
the time what was that difficult for you
it was you know obviously just like
anybody you know you don't want to those
guys I mean we were so close to were
like brothers yeah and you know lying to
them just it was a it was a terrible
thing it made me feel really bad that I
would ever do that to them and and I'm
guessing it wouldn't have been
necessarily your choice right I mean you
did you feel that this is just the way
it had to be because of the policy it
definitely had to be that way the Don't
Ask Don't Tell policy it was a it was a
don't get caught policies all it really
was it was a it was a nightmare and he
is a mess were you were you out to your
family at the time that you joined the
Navy I was I was you and what was that
experience like in other words was that
is that something that you you did right
away or what was the timeline of that
like I came out uh I was sort of outed
my mom overheard a phone call that I had
with a friend of mine who was gay when I
was believed 17 I was fairly young and
it didn't go long my like I said my
father was a you know colonel in the Air
Force and you know they were very
religious so he felt very strongly
against it and yeah it just it wasn't a
very good coming out in fact I got
kicked out of my house
and then ultimately were you allowed
back in what was that what was that
period of time like uh it was tough it
was uh it was probably one of the most
toughest times in my life you know there
was a lot of heavy thinking after I got
kicked out of the house and you know I
did eventually move back in with my
parents just prior to me joining the
Navy but it was a it was tough it was I
learned a lot though you know there
wasn't all bad you know I think in any
situation where we're bad things sort of
happened to the person you kind of grow
and learn from it and become a little
bit stronger now since your dad was in
the Air Force he of course must have
also been aware of what the policy was
so were there conversations with him
about your potential risk situation
there I don't you know honestly don't
recall a specific conversation I think
it was something the morale that we just
didn't talk about in fact after you know
after that you know getting kicked out
of the house we didn't we didn't talk
about my sexuality for years and when
you uh before leaving the Navy SEALs had
you come out yeah I was I was forced out
of the closet see I was a 2001 or no I'm
sorry yet 2002 rather I just got back
from doing a six-month deployment we
deployed two weeks after 9/11 and I got
back and I was the person I was living
with at the time when I was in a
relationship with had this big party for
me for you know coming back and you know
being healthy and you know all that and
I drank a little bit at that party and
then the next day you know I woke up and
I had realized that before I went to bed
that I probably didn't spend as much
time with him as I should have instead
you know talking with other you know
people at the party and I left I called
his office and left a message on the
machine and
is one of the people that work for him
heard that message and it was somebody
that he had recently just counseled so
she reported it and I was also for the
Navy to launch a full-scale
investigation so there was so quite
literally there was an investigation
into your sexual orientation by the Navy
yeah yep the last four months actually
and it's amazing to me how could it last
for months when it seems like it's all
about asking you as absurd as it is
what's your sexual orientation and
getting an answer in other words why did
they need to what was being investigated
so the Don't Ask Don't Tell policy is
just that it's Don't Ask Don't Tell so
you know they're trying to figure out
ways to get me to tell I remember you
know right when I came back off of the
the deployment you know I've met with
the investigator and I'm sorry actually
I went to a freefall school and then I
came back from that and that's when I
found out about the investigation and
you know this is an interrogation it was
about two hours of her trying any which
way she could to get me to say that I
was gay fortunately I got put in touch
with the eff LVN up in DC just prior to
that so they prepared me for the
questions that they were going to ask me
and the tactics that they were going to
use can you give us an example of what
types of questions they would ask to try
to get you to say something so they've
done their research they found that we
had bought a house together and that
both our names are on the house and so
they would say stuff like that and
somehow they were able to find out about
a vacation that we'd even gone on and
you know asked you know different
questions you know like why would you
buy a house with you know this guy or
why would you buy plane tickets to
travel together to this place or you
know it was the stuff like that and how
would you answer those questions I told
them that by the direction of the lawyer
I said I don't feel comfortable with
that question in that I need to discuss
that with my legal counsel
it would looking back at all of this now
I mean what what's your view on it
what's your view on Don't Ask Don't Tell
having been repealed I mean how to me it
seems like just almost an immoral waste
of resources that could be put into so
many other things you know looking back
on it it's honestly it's a really sad
part of our history but I'm actually
glad that it's it's history now yeah but
it's really sad I remember going to two
gay bars or whatever was in the Navy and
I could just see you know somebody that
had been you know kicked out of the Navy
for it this is the thing is getting
kicked out of the Nate I mean they would
try to disarm with this charge you which
is like being a convicted felon in a lot
of states and so you I mean you could
just see the shame on some of these
people's faces that you know you talk to
and you hear their story it was horrible
and it really is a black eye in our
history I think just because there were
so many people I believed you know like
an average of 300 a year in the Navy
alone we're kicked out under the Don't
Ask Don't Tell policy for being gay or
lesbian or transgender or whatever and
it was a it's sad because these are
people who really just wanted to serve
their country of course of course we've
been we've been speaking with Brett
Jones the name of the book is pride the
story of the first openly gay Navy SEAL
it's from dog-eared publishing Brett
really a pleasure having you on thanks
for telling us your story thanks right
out of me